this week hear blackb and I decided to
get together show some love to each
other you know just making sure my my my
my guy straight you know just making
sure he good checking in with them I
feel like if that didn't happen we won't
be here right now so it's a blessing
that that happened so now we can we can
show people the other side of football
like coming together letting everybody
know it's all positivity around the
world man you just got to be willing to
forgive and forget just accept that it
happened already I mean just us knowing
that we're a young man Even though
somebody made a mistake we come together
and then just show the people that you
got to have respect for each other show
the people the positive side of me I
don't like to be negative I'm not
negative it's hard to get me angry me
and him coming together just show a
different side of the world that like
there actually nice people out out in
the world and there always going to be
some positivity around my
name